je vous propose mes chers collègues que
nous puissions commencer cette table
ronde de notre huitième audition en
commission spéciale
nous avons décidé avec les rapporteurs
de la consacré un sujet qui est vraiment
au cœur des préoccupations du Sénat et
ce depuis assez longtemps et qui occupe
notamment les premiers articles du
projet de loi il s'agit de la protection
de l'enfance face à plusieurs phénomènes
les contenus pornographiques
pédopornographiques le cyber-harcèlement
aussi qui est une cause de grande
préoccupations
qui avait l'objet d'un travail de la
commission culture éducation donc mes
chers collègues j'accueillent votre nom
Monsieur Olivier Gérard qui est
coordonnateur du pôle média
usage numérique de l'Union nationale des
associations familiales bienvenue à vous
Monsieur Gérard
j'accueille en votre nom également
monsieur
melon qu'il déléguait général du Conseil
français des associations pour les
Droits de l'Enfant autrement appelé
Cofrad et Madame angélique gosseland qui
est membre du comité d'experts de
l'Observatoire de la parentalité de
l'éducation numérique donc comme je
disais je suis la protection de
l'enfance est au cœur de nos
préoccupations je sais que vous avez été
déjà et plusieurs fois entendu sur les
différents textes que nous avons porté
dans cet assemblé ou les différents
rapports qu'on a pu faire également je
pourrais citer le travail pionnier de la
délégation droit des femmes dont je
salue les membres ici présents ce
travail qui portait sur la nurserie
pornographique qui a souligné les
ravages d'un accès totalement libre à
des contenus plus inappropriés pour les
mineurs selon la dernière enquête de
l'arcom c'est bon toujours de citer des
chiffres aussi pour voir l'ampleur du
phénomène
2,3 millions de mineurs chaque mois des
sites pornographiques c'est la cause 2,3
millions de mineurs dès 12 ans la moitié
des garçons se rendent en moyenne au
moins une fois par mois sur l'un de ces
sites je crois que ceci est assez
révélateur et notre assemblée sonore à
initiative notre collègue Marie Mercier
qui est membre des êtres commissions et
que je salue d'avoir voulu y mettre un
terme des 2020
de l'autre côté du spectre on a cette
actualité qui est dramatique avec le
suicide de la jeune lycée mais aussi du
jeune Thibault plus récemment qui nous a
tous rappelés l'urgence à agir contre le
cyber-harcèlement faciliter par bien
entendu les réseaux sociaux et la façon
qu'il fonctionne pour que ce soit permis
de telles dérives
et ce afin que le monde numérique ne se
transforme pas on a Monte totalement
dénué de règles donc on le voit ce sont
les mineurs qui sont les premiers
victimes du développement des outils
numériques je serai aussi signaler que
récemment nous avons adopté une
proposition de loi de notre collègue
Alexandra borchio Fontain était
rapporteur sur la majorité numérique à
15 ans pour l'accès aux réseaux sociaux
c'est aujourd'hui même je crois dans
l'heure qui précède cette audition que a
été conclue la commission mixte
paritaire entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale et on ne peut que s'en réjouir
jouer aussi rappeler le travail que nous
avons fait avec mes collègues Ludovic et
André rachat de la commission des
affaires européennes nous avons fait
voté le 10 juin dernier à l'unanimité
une proposition de résolution européenne
portant sur le la proposition de
règlement européen qui vise à établir
des règles en vue de prévenir les
combats que les abus sexuels sur les
enfants un texte encore en cours de
négociation
au niveau européen voilà les éléments de
contexte dans le cadre desquels nous
sommes heureux de vous entendre un
patient de vous entendre tout d'abord
bien sûr sur le constat mais plus encore
ce qui va nous être utile sur votre
appréciation des dispositions qui vont
pouvoir être prises grâce à ce texte
application dérèglement
européen je vais vous donner
successivement la parole je vais
commencer par Monsieur Gérard donc de
une aphte chacun d'entre vous à peu près
pour 10 minutes pour qu'après on puisse
avoir un temps vraiment d'échanges
qui soit propice voilà à notre réflexion
et à l'amélioration du texte au temps
que faire ce peu voilà Monsieur Gérard
vous avez la parole bonjour à tous
d'abord merci madame la Présidente et
merci à vous tous d'être là et de nous
donner l'occasion de nous exprimer donc
vous l'avez effectivement souligné le
texte sur lequel on a amené à échanger
aujourd'hui est un texte qui s'inscrit
dans finalement dans un foisonnement
d'initiative parlementaire et
réglementaire ce qui traduit aussi et
pour nous c'est important une volonté
forte des pouvoirs publics d'agir et
d'apaiser l'espace numérique c'était
évidemment un enjeu prioritaire et
important pour pour les familles que
nous représentons et nous nous sommes
les porte-paroles c'est aussi un enjeu
important dans la mesure où cette
impulsion politique elle nous semble
absolument nécessaire pour qu'on puisse
collectivement faire bouger les lignes
puisque évidemment sur sur ces sujets là
les modifications les évolutions
réglementaires et législatives ne suff
pas il est nécessaire d'avoir
véritablement une action collective qui
associe l'ensemble des acteurs
l'ensemble de des parties prenantes et
l'occasion d'y revenir alors peut-être
d'abord sur les éléments de contexte
vous avez cité à certains noms de
chiffres en particulier pour ce qui
relève de la pornographie l'étude de
l'arcome qui finalement conforté et
confirmé les données du rapport du Sénat
de l'année passée sur sur la
pornographie c'est vrai que c'est un
c'est une étude qui a permis de
véritablement
donner des éléments concrets pour enfin
on puisse avoir des informations sur sur
l'accès des mineurs des chiffres
évidemment assez éloquants édifiants je
vais pas y revenir vous en avez cité un
certain nombre je n'entrais peut-être un
aspect un aspect important parce que
pour nous il est il est aussi
significatif c'est qu'effectivement dans
cet accès à la pornographie vous avez
cité beaucoup de chiffres
de garder à l'esprit que le premier
levier d'accès surtout
[Musique]
on pourrait rajouter également un
certain nombre d'études qui ont été
faites autour de la problématique des
violences en ligne des propos haineux
qui sont aujourd'hui un enjeu
extrêmement important et qui sont
peut-être toi parfois un élément qui
s'inscrit dans le champ du
cyberharcèlement mais pas que et c'est
aussi une problématique qui pour nous
est extrêmement extrêmement importante
peut-être aussi vous citez quelques
quelques données du côté du côté des
familles et des parents puisque nous
sommes 2009 d'abord
la dernière étude qu'on n'a pas encore
publié qu'on va publier montre que que
ces questions et en particulier la
question du harcèlement est aujourd'hui
jugé par par les parents comme le
principal sujet d'inquiétude pour tout
ce qui a trait à la santé des enfants
c'est à dire qu'on a dans le cas des
futurs assises de la pédiatrie qui ont
qui ont eu lieu très prochainement on a
mené une enquête auprès des familles qui
montrent que cette question du
harcèlement est vraiment le sujet
principale de préoccupations qu'il y
avait évidemment une vraie demande
d'accompagnement et de soutien des
parents et en tout cas vraiment à ce que
des des mesures soient prises pour
lutter contre contre ce dispositif bien
au-delà de des questions autour du
malaise de l'addition des troubles
alimentaires ou encore du sommeil c'est
véritablement aujourd'hui bien perçu
comme un enjeu important et c'est pour
nous
essentiel d'avoir cette information et
puis relever aussi que encore une fois
au-delà des mesures législatives les
parents étaient finalement en attente
d'information sur ces questions de
harcèlement et que en dépit de tout ce
qui a pu déjà être mis on constate que
beaucoup de parents sont encore non pas
tous les éléments suffisants autour de
ces questions on retrouve des parfois
des phénomènes un peu similaires autour
des enjeux de pornographie donc c'est
quand même aussi pour nous important de
de garder cet aspect là de continuer à
informer sensibiliser et accompagner les
parents sur toutes ces problématiques
voilà pour le constat on pourra revenir
sur un certain nombre d'éléments si vous
le souhaitez mais peut-être le temps est
parti aller directement sur les mesures
du projet de loi
on a regardé l'ensemble de ce projet loi
mais on va intervenir là aujourd'hui que
sur que sur les premières les premiers
articles en tout cas ceux qui relèvent
de la protection de l'enfance
globalement
les mesures qui sont qui sont proposées
vont s'inscrire véritablement dans une
dans une avancée positive en tout cas
pour pour nous à Luna ce sont des
mesures qui qui étaient nécessaires de
prendre je vais revenir mais on a quand
même peut-être un point d'alerte qui est
qui est général c'est
sur le fait qu'il y a certains nombre de
mesures ou de disposition qui sont
parfois pris dans l'univers du numérique
souffre à la fois de leur mise en œuvre
opérationnelle
mais également sur les délais qui sont
derrière nécessaires pour pour être
opérationnel je vais prendre deux
exemples puisque vous évoquez le projet
loi autour de la majorité numérique à 15
ans qui a donc été si j'ai bien suivi
vous conclu cette après-midi
on s'aperçoit par exemple que les
articles relativent à la protection des
mineurs du rgpd qui prévoyait notamment
une forte implication et un consentement
par les parents par exemple pour les
enfants de 13 à 15 ans nous grosso modo
pas été mis en oeuvre pourtant nous
sommes aujourd'hui cinq ans après le
rgpd on s'aperçoit que derrière les
textes il n'y a pas eu de suivi
opérationnel donc c'est pour nous
toujours un point d'alerte que ces
dispositions juridiques et législatives
soient suivies des faits opérationnels
même si on conçoit qu'il peut y avoir
des complexité et que c'est ce sont des
choses qui sont parfois compliquées à
mettre en place et deuxième exemple
c'est sur le la loi sur le contrôle
parental donc qui avait été voté à
l'initiative de Bruno Studer en mars
2022 et qui qui ne rentrera en vigueur
que fin du premier semestre 2024 si tout
va bien et c'est vrai que pour nous
c'est aussi des éléments de
préoccupation c'est qu'on est face à des
urgences on l'a vu à travers les
chiffres on est face à des vrais
attentes des publics des familles des
enfants et avec d'abord jeux de santé
publique probablement et on est sur sur
des univers numériques ou les choses
évidemment très vite et parfois on se
heurte à des délais de mise en oeuvre
qui sont qui sont au fond difficile
aussi à expliquer à justifier auprès des
auprès des parents donc c'est un point
c'est un point général qui nous semble
important de souligner si on rentre plus
généralement sur les sur les articles
donc sur le le les articles qui
concernent l'accès à la à la
pornographie en particulier l'article 1
et 2 d'abord vous dire que
l'une des mesures importantes c'est
effectivement le le nouveau rôle ou le
renforcement du rôle confié à la COM qui
qui
dans la volonté justement de de réduire
de raccourcir les délais d'intervention
et on l'a vu on est avec l'Open
d'ailleurs à l'initiative d'une saisie
des fin 2020 de l'arcom et on s'aperçoit
qu'aujourd'hui les mesures les
décisions judiciaires n'ont toujours pas
été prises et qu'il y a probablement à
il y avait probablement nécessité à
repenser le dispositif pour être sur
quelque chose qui soit beaucoup plus
réactif et beaucoup plus
utile au regard de l'urgence d'agir et
du sujet dont il s'agit donc pour nous
c'est la possibilité parmi à l'arcom de
finalement prendre des des injonctions
et des décisions administratives qu'il
s'agisse de bloquer les sites des
référencés voire de prendre des
sanctions pécuniaires sont des mesures
qui qui s'inscrivent dans une dans une
avancée très très positive et qui on
l'espère permettront de plus rapidement
avec évidemment la mise en place de de
de
possibilités
d'appel et
d'éléments contradictoires par ceux qui
seront concernés mais en tout cas ce
sera sans doute un moyen nécessaire pour
aller pour aller plus vite et pour
finalement aussi lever la compréhension
que nous font parler sur le terrain qui
nous comprennent pas pourquoi on regarde
des enjeux qu'on évoque très
régulièrement on a le sentiment que que
les dispositions légales que les choses
n'avancent pas et qu'il y a la
véritablement un espèce
d'incompréhension sur sur l'urgence et
sur les enjeux et sur ce qui est
concrètement mis en place donc c'est un
texte qui pour nous et relativement
positif avec peut-être
deux remarques sur le sur le texte
d'abord c'est vrai que les textes
évoquent évoquent beaucoup la question
des sites de communication en ligne donc
on pense en particulier les sites les
sites pornographiques mais peut-être
rappeler quand même que l'accès des
mineurs au contenu pornographique ne
passent pas seulement par l'accès au
site pornographique mais qu'il y a
évidemment tout un ensemble d'autres
leviers d'autres moyens d'accéder à des
contenus pornographiques et évidemment
toute la question des réseaux sociaux la
question des messageries privées et
simplement la question de
transmission de contenu
pornographiques y compris entre entre
les jeunes eux-mêmes et notamment via le
téléphone portable donc c'est aussi
rappeler que
au-delà de de ces mesures de cette
mesure qui ont l'espère permettra de
contraindre et de bloquer l'accès des
mineurs aussi de pornographiques
évidemment toutes les tous les enjeux ne
vont pas être résolus par cette
disposition
le deuxième point qui est qui est prévu
donc c'est l'article premier je l'ai
fait dans un dans le désordre excusez
moi c'est sur les recommandations
techniques et notamment sur sur les
dispositifs de vérification d'âge là
aussi pour nous c'est une avancée
importante c'est une avancée importante
parce qu'on l'a bien vu c'est ces
derniers mois
les débats les discussions portées
essentiellement sur l'absence de d'un
cadre d'un cadre référentiel même si
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il existe un
certain nombre de solutions techniques
qui qui sont proposées sur le marché et
qui peuvent répondre à la fois cette
exigence de vérifier l'âge mais aussi de
respecter à certains nombre de d'enjeux
sociétaux et notamment de respecter le
principe du double anonymat qui est
évoqué par la palaknil néanmoins cette
proposition de mettre en place
assez rapidement des recommandations
techniques nous sommes être une avancée
absolument nécessaire avec avec en plus
l'idée d'avoir une valeur contraignante
à cette à côtier va se référentiel et
pour nous c'est aussi quelque chose
d'important il s'agit plus aujourd'hui
simplement de d'inciter d'inviter
d'encourager mais bien de contraindre de
contraindre les acteurs du les sites
internet qui proposent des contenus
pornographiques de mettre en place les
mesures et d'appliquer la loi donc tout
ce qui va dans ce sens là va dans le
sens de la protection des enfants et
donc évidemment une mesure très
satisfaisante
peut-être une interrogation
semble que le texte justement sur la
mise en place de ce référence de ce
référentiel on précise pas de délai de
donne pas de de données sur trois mois
six mois après la mise en oeuvre de la
loi donc c'est toujours une incertitude
lorsqu'il y a pas de délai dans la
mesure où ça laisse une une possibilité
que les les référentiel voilà n'est pas
cette obligation de résultats quelque
part fixé voilà c'est pour nous un point
un point d'attention qui qui nous
semblait important de souligner donc ça
c'était sur sur les mesures autour de
la pornographie sur la sur le sujet du
cyber-harcèlement et de la lutte contre
le contre le cyber-harcèlement donc en
particulier l'article 5 il vise à
sanctionner les auteurs à travers une
peine complémentaire qui serait une
suspension en fait des comptes c'est
évidemment pour nous
là à nouveau une avancée extrêmement
positive qui vise à protéger les
victimes et puis en évitant surtout que
les pratiques se poursuivent
au-delà de de des décisions qui ont pu
être prises c'est finalement lutter
contre ce sentiment
d'impunité que finalement on peut
on peut condamner les personnes mais
elles vont pouvoir continuer leur
forfait et donc c'est pour nous quelque
chose qui est absolument nécessaire avec
quelques points de de vigilance
alors le texte évidemment
prévoit de bloquer l'utilisation de la
plateforme qui a fait l'objet
d'une incrimination de d'évent vraiment
bloquer l'ensemble des sites palpard
dans l'ensemble des comptes de la
personne mais c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
on peut être des situations où le
cyberlement va utiliser plusieurs canaux
plusieurs plateformes et que il y a sans
doute avoir une réflexion sur comment
est-ce qu'on peut avoir peut-être des
des suspensions qui seraient des
suspensions un peu plus en cascade et
qu'on ne reste pas sur une seule
plateforme de la mesure où parfois les
situations de harceleur de harcèlement
utilisent évidemment plusieurs canaux ça
peut être des réseaux sociaux des
messageries et tout autre dispositif et
il faut que
la sanction concerne l'ensemble des des
canaux qui ont pu être utilisés et qu'on
évite à nouveau que ces situations
perdure
je pense quand même que peut-être un
point qui qui nous semble aussi
important sur ces questions de
harcèlement même si c'est pas l'objet de
la loi et vous l'avez souligné il y a
des travaux qui sont qui sont menés sur
ces questions par ailleurs peut-être de
rappeler que pour nous le la lutte
contre le cyber-harcèlement c'est
effectivement trois piliers c'est
sanctionner les auteurs et l'article 5
s'inscrit dans cette dans cette axe là
c'est évidemment sensibilisé l'ensemble
des des parties prenantes à la fois ceux
qui sont victimes ceux qui sont les
harceleurs et puis tout toute la tous
les tous les autres gérer tout ce qui
sont entre le harceleur et le harcelé
mais aussi c'est un point important
d'accompagner les victimes et peut-être
rappeler qu'on est aujourd'hui dans une
situation où nous semble-t-il les les
moyens à louer notamment à
l'accompagnement des personnes des
enfants mais aussi de leur famille qui
sont victimes de harcèlement semble
insuffisant on a un certain nombre
d'actions qui sont menées nous sur les
territoires par notre réseau autour de
ces questions d'accompagnement des
familles et des enfants victimes ou
harceleurs d'ailleurs et on est sur sur
des services qui sont absolument saturés
mais qui n'ont pas aujourd'hui les les
moyens pour aller plus loin pour se
développer et entraînant en fait des
impossibilités d'accompagner de manière
satisfaisante ces familles et donc
finalement de laisser ces familles ou
ses enfants victimes du harcèlement sans
accompagnement adapté donc c'était
important de le souligner même si j'ai
bien conscience que c'est que ce n'est
pas l'objet de la loi et peut-être pour
pour terminer et rester dans le temps
imparti rappeler évidemment que et je le
disais en introduction que ces enjeux
que ce soit la lutte contre l'accès à la
pornographie le cyber-harcèlement et
plus généralement la question la
protection des enfants en ligne il y a
aussi évidemment beaucoup d'enjeux
éducatifs derrière et notamment à la
fois de renforcer les dispositifs de
prévention d'éducation auprès des jeunes
il faut continuer il faut permettre aux
jeunes finalement d'adopter aussi de
nouveaux réflexes en ligne d'être dans
une autre approche peut-être de ce qu'on
peut faire en ligne est-ce qu'on ne peut
pas faire de ce qui est acceptable ce
qui n'est pas acceptable mais aussi
c'est vous comprendrez bien venant de
Luna fait un jeu important pour nous
continuer à soutenir accompagner aussi
les parents parce que la régulation
l'apaisement de ces mots numériques
c'est bien obligé de cette loi passe
aussi par le rôle essentiel des parents
et de la famille qu'il s'agisse de la
prévention primaire qu'il s'agisse de de
la place et la présence parentale de
continuer à proposer des dispositifs sur
le terrain qui accompagnent les parents
on a on vient de lancer nous un
dispositif en lien avec avec le la DGCS
la CNAF et les ministres et les trois
ministères un dispositif de
labellisation des des actions de
parentalité numérique
évidemment dans l'ensemble de ce qui est
proposé sur le terrain les questions de
pornographie qu'il s'agisse de lutter
contre l'accès des mineurs mais aussi
autour de l'éducation sexuelle de
l'éducation affective la question de
cyber-harcèlement sont évidemment
largement traitées mais il faut
continuer sur le terrain à développer ce
type d'initiative parce que c'est bien
en ayant une approche complémentaire
que l'on arrivera à
faire face à ce fléau et un dernier
point pour pour terminer mais j'ai
évoqué effectivement à plusieurs
reprises la question du smartphone et
dans les études qu'on avait menées à
nouveau notamment avec avec l'Open sur
sur ces questions de
d'usage du numérique parmi les chiffres
qui étaient sortis évidemment la place
prépondérante du smartphone du téléphone
portable et c'est vrai que je le disais
l'accès au contenu pornographique le
cybarcellement la ligne ça passe
beaucoup par le smartphone et
et c'est un peu le grand absent ce
projet de loi dans la mesure où on
aurait pu imaginer un certain nombre de
dispositifs ou de mesures spécifiques à
cette question du du téléphone portable
en particulier ce constat qui est
finalement qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes
sont équipés de manière très précoce et
son voie sont souvent équipés sur les
avec les mêmes outils que nous alors
qu'ils n'ont pas évidemment la même
capacité la même maturité pour utiliser
ces outils et donc effectivement
l'éducation l'accompagnement est
important mais c'est peut-être aussi se
réinterroger sur la place du smartphone
dans notre société sur la question de
l'autorisation l'utilisation ou
l'interdiction du smartphone chez chez
les enfants est-ce que est-ce qu'on
devrait pas aller un peu plus loin je
n'ai pas forcément de mesures concrète à
vous proposer mais c'est vrai que c'est
pour nous une préoccupation importante
de se dire que si on veut aussi lutter
contre toutes ces dérives si on veut
mieux protéger nos enfants il faut sans
doute aujourd'hui reposer la question de
notamment du smartphone qui est un objet
par nature difficile à accompagner
difficile à surveiller difficile à
encadrer
et qui et qui est laissé dans les mettre
des enfants de manière très précoce et
c'est pour nous un vrai point
d'interrogation et sans doute une
réflexion à mener voilà merci beaucoup
merci
Monsieur Gérard je donne tout de suite
la parole à Monsieur Arthur Melun
merci Madame la présidence mesdames
Messieurs les élus
alors bien entendu le coffrade se
félicite du fait que les pouvoirs
publics se saisissent de cette question
de l'exposition des mineurs à la
pornographie c'est essentiellement sur
ce sujet que je vais m'exprimer
cela étant à la lecture des articles en
question je dois admettre que j'ai
ressenti plutôt de la colère que du
soulagement
la colère parce que j'ai le sentiment
que
les deux assemblées parlementaires
votent des lois qui sont des lois bien
faites et qu'elles ne sont pas
appliquées et que on ajoute de nouvelles
lois pour
trouver prétexte à ne pas appliquer les
précédentes dispositions législatives
que vous avez bien rédigé et qui à mon
sens sont parfaitement suffisantes
je fais référence d'une part
à l'article 227-24 du code pénal qui
prévoit une sanction pour les personnes
qui mettrait à disposition des contenus
pornographiques susceptibles d'être
perçu par des mineurs
et je ferai référence également
à la loi qui donne à la recom et la
justice la possibilité de des référencer
et de bloquer les sites qui
contreviendraient à ces dispositions
selon moi l'arsenal législatif
actuellement en vigueur est suffisant
pour s'attaquer au cœur du problème et
le cœur du problème vous vous l'avez
rappelé madame la Présidente il y a eu
une enquête de Mediamétrie de l'arcom
le cœur du poème c'est pornhub youporn
et les autres plateformes de ce type
puisque cette enquête a montré que 60%
des contenus pornographiques consommés
par les mineurs se concentre proviennent
d'uniquement 5 plateformes
pornographiques
ce sont ces cinq plateformes qui donnent
lieu actuellement à beaucoup de débats
et j'ai le sentiment que une section
entière de ce projet de loi est consacré
finalement uniquement à pornhub et
compagnie puisque les autres plateformes
pornographiques classiques qui font
payer leur contenu comme ça a été le cas
jusque à l'apparition des tubes
visiblement aujourd'hui ne pose pas de
problème particulier en termes
d'exposition des mineurs la pornographie
la question que je pose donc c'est y
a-t-il besoin de faire une section dans
un nouveau projet de loi une nouvelle
section dans un projet de loi pour
contraindre enfin ces cinq gros tubes à
se conformer à la loi alors même qui se
font l'objet de deux procédures
judiciaires une procédure au pénale et
une procédure aussi ville par
l'intermédiaire des fournisseurs d'accès
Internet
la procédure au pénale a été initié en
2018 sur les fondements sur le fondement
de l'article 227 24 du code pénal
plainte déposées par le coffrade et par
l'Open nous n'avons à ce jour au bout de
5 ans aucune nouvelle de cette plainte
déposée
devant le ministère public
autre procédure lancée auprès de l'arcom
donc fin 2020 si ma mémoire est exacte
qui à force de manœuvre dilatoire nous
conduit en 2023 avec toujours et encore
des millions de visites de mineurs sur
ces sites pornographiques qui
visiblement n'ont pas l'intention de
prendre les moindres mesures pour
prendre leur responsabilité vis-à-vis de
la loi et vis-à-vis des mineurs donc je
questionne d'emblée l'utilité de
d'adopter de nouvelles mesures
législatives alors que ce n'est pas mon
ma propre opinion le conseil la Cour de
cassation pardon a rappelé dans un arrêt
récent que la loi est parfaitement
claire que la loi est parfaitement
constitutionnelle malgré ce que
prétendent les sites pornographiques et
qu'il n'y a donc aucune difficulté pour
que le tribunal prenne la décision qui
s'impose c'est-à-dire demander au
fournisseur d'accès Internet de couper
l'accès à ces sites
c'était mon propos préliminaire
sur l'article premier
nous avons la ligne à deux qui nous
explique que l'Autorité de régulation
des communications de visuelles et
numérique
veillera à ce que les contenus
pornographiques mis à disposition du
public par un service de communication
au public en ligne ne puisse pas être
accessible au mineur je comprends
parfaitement l'intention derrière cet
article qui est de nous expliquer que
l'arcom va être désormais l'autorité de
référence par rapport à la protection
des mineurs face au contenu
pornographique je m'interroge néanmoins
sur la pertinence de cette formulation
est-ce à l'arcom de veiller à ce que les
contenus pornographiques ne soient pas
accessibles aux mineurs ou est-ce au
fournisseur de contenu pornographiques
de veiller à ce que leur propre contenu
qu'ils mettent eux-mêmes sur Internet ne
soit pas accessible aux mineurs
et ce qu'il ne vaudrait pas mieux une
formulation qui rappelle que l'arcome
est là pour s'assurer que les
fournisseurs de contenus pornographiques
s'assure de leur obligation légale plus
que tout que dont nous expliquer que
l'arcom va veiller elle-même à ce que
ces contenus ne soient pas accessibles
aux mineurs
nous avons ensuite la ligne à 3
qui prévoit que l'arcome va édicter des
lignes directrices pour que les
plateformes puissent avoir comment
protéger les mineurs face à leur contenu
je tiens souligner le fait que cette
alinéa va parfaitement dans la ligne
stratégique de défense soutenue depuis
plusieurs mois par les plateformes
pornographiques que nous ont-elles dit
pornhub et compagnie nous dit on ne peut
pas se conformer à la loi on ne peut pas
se conformer à l'article 227 24 puisque
la loi n'est pas claire puisque l'arcome
et la CNIL ne nous disent pas comment
faire pour protéger les mineurs face au
contenu pornographique
et puisque la loi n'est pas claire nous
ne pouvons pas nous y conformer donc
nous considérons que c'est une loi
anticonstitutionnelle puisqu'elle ne
respecte pas la légalité des délices et
des persils de l'égalité des délices et
des peines et donc nous allons porter
cette affaire en question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité
ce à quoi je le rappelle la Cour de
cassation a estimé que la loi était
parfaitement claire et qu'à ce titre les
plateformes n'avaient pas besoin de
ligne directrice pour se conformer à la
loi et devait elle-même prendre les
mesures qui s'imposaient pour s'assurer
que leur contenu ne soit pas accessible
aux mineurs
donc j'attire votre attention sur le
fait que cette alinéa donne raison aux
plateformes en suggérant
qu'effectivement il est nécessaire que
les pouvoirs publics expliquent au
fournisseurs de contenu pornographiques
comment bien faire leur travail pour
s'assurer que les mineurs ne soient bien
en danger
la deuxième remarque que je ferai sur
cet alinéa c'est que à ce jour
les articles du Code pénal
donc le l'article 227 qui arrive 24
et la loi qui prévoit le des
référencement des sites Internet par le
biais de de l'arcom et de du tribunal
judiciaire
sont des lois qui posent un principe de
principe de résultats une obligation de
résultats
aujourd'hui si une plateforme n'est pas
en mesure de s'assurer que ces contenus
pornographiques ne sont pas accessibles
à des mineurs alors cette plateforme n'a
pas le droit de faire trafic de ces
contenus pornographiques qui est une
obligation de résultat auquel cas elle
s'expose à des sanctions pénales
ce que je crains c'est qu'avec cette
alinéa qui prévoit que l'arcome va
édicter des lignes directrices c'est
qu'on passe d'une obligation de
résultats une obligation de moyens et
que demain pornhub face au constat que
des mineurs ont toujours accès à ces
sites nous explique mais nous on sait
parfaitement conformer aux lignes
directrices de l'arcome donc s'il y a
des problèmes avec nos solutions
techniques il faut se retourner vers
l'arcom qui est seul
la seule autorité pour dire quelles sont
les mesures adéquates pour s'assurer la
protection des mineurs
or les technologies du numérique
évoluent extrêmement vite
on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui
d'intelligence artificielle on ne sait
pas demain quels seront les mesures qui
permettront de vérifier l'âge des
mineurs quels seront les mesures qui
permettront aux mineurs de dissimuler
leur variage donc on est en train de
demander à l'arcom d'être dans une
course sans fin pour toujours adapter
ses lignes directrices et les
plateformes n'auront plus qu'à attendre
que l'arcome leur donne des nouvelles
directives pour se conformer et je
crains encore une fois que les
plateformes se réfugient derrière les
directives de l'art comme pour dire on a
fait notre travail c'est pas notre faute
si des mineurs continuent à avoir accès
au site pornographique
c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose qui a
posé problème au Royaume-Uni puisqu'on
Royaume-Uni depuis 2017 ils essayent
également d'imposer le contrôle d'âge
par les plateformes et cette fois-ci au
Royaume-Uni ce sont les autorités
publiques qui indiquent une liste de
mesures techniques et réglementaire pour
pouvoir s'y conformer et on sait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un fiasco
et je tiens à rappeler un principe c'est
que les plateformes essayent de nous
faire croire que
si aujourd'hui les contenus
pornographiques sont accessibles aux
mineurs
c'est le problème de la législation
c'est le problème de la technique on
n'aurait pas les technologies
nécessaires
mais l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
exige de réfléchir à l'inverse
si aujourd'hui vous estimez que la que
la technologie n'est pas nécessaire pour
contrôler l'âge des mineurs alors la loi
implique que vous ne pouvez pas faire
commerce de ces contenus pornographiques
il faut remettre le principe de
protection de l'enfance et de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant en priorité et non
pas se dire qu'on va sacrifier l'intérêt
de l'enfant sur l'Hôtel des solutions
techniques qui se font toujours attendre
j'en viens à la Linéa 6 qui prévoit une
amende de 75000 euros qui peut monter
jusqu'à 150 000 euros
quand on connaît le chiffre d'affaires
de ces plateformes
on se dit qu'en fait elles vont
provisionner 75000 euros sur leur budget
annuel et qu'elles vont continuer leur
business asiews
honnêtement je vois pas en quoi s'est
dissuasif 75000 euros pour pornhub je ne
vois pas en quoi c'est dysphasif c'est
peut-être une fraction de ce qu'ils ont
payé en guise en frais d'avocat cette
année pour pour le procès qu'on leur a
intenté
je souligne également le fait que ces
plateformes qui posent problème ne sont
pas fiscalement domiciliés en France
je ne connais pas exactement je m'y
connais pas en droit fiscal je me
demande quels vont être les procédures
engagées pour aller recouvrir 75000
euros dans un pays étranger et combien
ça va coûter en procédure et pour le
contribuable français par le biais de
l'administration est-ce que ça va valoir
est-ce que ça va vouloir vendre 75000
euros je me demande si c'est 75000 euros
ce sera pas la purpette quand ce sera
récupérée de la part de ces plateformes
parce qu'on aura fait des procédures
internationales interminables pour
pouvoir récupérer une somme qui est
vraiment ridicule au regard de chiffre
d'affaires de ces plateformes
et enfin
je pense que même si effectivement
Olivier Gérard l'a rappelé aujourd'hui
les procédures judiciaires sont beaucoup
trop longues par rapport à l'urgence de
la situation ça fait trois ans que nous
essayons de faire bloquer les sites en
question je comprends donc l'idée de
permettre à l'arcome de prendre la
décision seule de suspendre les sites
internet je pose simplement la question
de la constitutionnalité d'une telle
mesure et ne doutez pas un instant que
dès lors que l'arcom voudra bloquer les
sites internet qu'il ne se gêneront pas
pour faire une nouvelle QPC pour estimer
qu'il s'agit d'une mesure
anticonstitutionnelle et pour bloquer
cette décision
simplement maintenant de remarques
concernant l'article 3 qui porte sur le
la pénalisation des plateformes qui ne
retiraient pas les contenus à caractère
pédopornographique
nous avons la ligne à 3 qui nous
explique que si les personnes
mentionnées ou un
ne peuvent se conformer à une demande de
retrait pour des motifs tenant la force
majeur ou à une impossibilité de fait
qui ne lui sont pas imputables
allez en informe de ces motifs sans
retards
j'aimerais bien un exemple
dernière remarque
je constate que dans cette proposition
dans ce projet de loi
il n'est question uniquement du retrait
des contenus pour nous
pédopornographiques comme s'il
s'agissait de simples images et qui
avait personne derrière derrière ces
contenus pornographiques il y a des
auteurs de pédocriminalité et il y a des
victimes
je ne constate pas dans ce projet de loi
ni dans la loi du 21 juin 2004 qui est
amendé par ses amendements de mentions
d'enquête qui devrait être lancée
automatiquement pour
identifier les victimes et identifier
les auteurs et s'assurer que les
victimes reçoivent l'assistance et
l'accompagnement nécessaire et que les
auteurs soient traduits dans la justice
et j'en ai terminé merci madame la
Présidente
je vous remercie donc je passe la madame
angélique Gosselin pour son intervention
allez-y madame
bonsoir alors j'interviens en tant
qu'expert de l'Open et mais j'aimerais
quand même préciser que je suis docteur
en psychopathologie et psychologue
clinicienne ce qui implique un voilà un
courant de pensée particulier par
rapport aux enfants et aux adolescents
alors
l'Open salue véritablement le travail
engagé dans ce projet de loi qui marque
d'un point de vue symbolique éligi et
législatif un tournant quant à la
protection des mineurs sur un sur
Internet cela permet en effet d'envoyer
un signal très fort sur l'intérêt
politique porté à cette question
fondamentale pour autant l'Open souhaite
néanmoins souligner plusieurs points
quant à ce projet de loi et donc je vais
m'exprimer très rapidement sur la
pornographie puisque nous rejoignons
complètement les les indications et les
remarques d'Arthur melon donc vraiment
je vais être très centré mon propos
ensuite sur le cyber-harcèlement alors
sur le sujet de la porn photographie
nous rejoignons lunaf et le Cofrad sur
la question des pouvoirs accordés à
l'arcom bien évidemment ceci est soutenu
par l'Open même si il y a une question
sur son effectivité au regard à des
pouvoirs législatifs concernant les
sanctions pénales et administratives
impliquant une amende à l'encontre des
sites donnant accès à des contenus
pornographiques à des mineurs il se pose
véritablement la question de
l'application de ces mesures comme la
souligner Arthur melon en effet beaucoup
de ces sites profitent des paradis
fiscaux et donc comment appliquer ses
amandes à des noms qui sont opacifiés
des noms d'entreprises et dirigeants
enfin concernant les exigences de
contrôle dash soumise au respect de la
vie privée l'Open pointe qu'il est
absolument nécessaire de veiller à ne
pas sacrifier la protection de l'enfant
au profit de la protection des données
rappelons qu'un mineur dans un
supermarché qui souhaite acheter de
l'alcool et bien on lui de sa carte
d'identité et c'est une question
inconnue qui va regarder sa carte
d'identité ici il n'est pas question de
protection des données personnelles
alors ceci d'autant plus que les
solutions techniques à déployer pour que
la corrélation contrôle d'âge et
protection des données soit opérantes ne
sont aujourd'hui pas existants l'Open
propose donc d'appliquer le principe de
la carte bleue qui est un principe
facile et rapide à mettre en place étant
donné qu'aucun mineur en France ne peut
accéder à une carte bleue dans un
établissement bancaire ceci répondrait
du coup à la remarque de Monsieur Gérard
sur les délais de mise en place d'un tel
projet de loi
pour conclure sur ce volet l'Open
soutient la volonté de régulation des
sites pornographiques bien évidemment
mais nous insistons sur l'importance
d'une telle régulation que cette
régulation doit absolument se faire au
nom de la cohérence éducative nous
regrettons l'inexistence dans ce projet
de la question de l'éducation pour les
mineurs mais surtout pour les adultes
ceci nous amène à deux points essentiels
et manquants dans ce projet de loi la
question de l'éducation auprès des
enfants et des adolescents il est
important de promouvoir l'obligation
d'une éducation aux médias et au
numérique et j'y reviendrai plus
précisément sur le volet de du
cyber-harcèlement et aussi bien une
éducation sexuelle qui ne soit pas une
éducation à la santé sexuelle la nuance
est ici très grande il s'agit
d'accompagner les enfants et les
adolescents sur les questions de
consentement sur les questions de
plaisir sexuels de connaissance de son
propre corps au regard du corps de
l'autre
de relations sexuelles de conditions de
l'homme et de la femme et non seulement
de les accompagner sur une prévention
des risques sexuels tels que les
grossesses en volontaires et les MST
même si ceux-ci est incontournable
évidemment mais limite les perspectives
de protection des mineurs ouvrir sur ses
enjeux d'éducation c'est apporter aux
enfants et aux adolescents la
possibilité de créer un regard critique
de se défendre de certaines
représentations véhiculées par la
pornographie et de permettre une vie
sexuelle dans le respect d'autrui le
deuxième point manquant est la question
de l'implication et de l'éducation des
adultes à l'accompagnement des enfants
et des adolescents sur les espaces
numériques il est important de soutenir
parents éducateurs adultes toute
personne s'occupant des enfants ou des
adolescents à construire une éducation
aux médias et au numérique prenant en
considération ce risque d'exposition à
des images pornographiques nous sommes
comme la première génération de parents
à devoir construire une éducation
numérique ce qui n'existait pas
auparavant et c'est un point essentiel à
souligner protéger les enfants oui mais
on impliquant les adultes qui les
entourent en les responsabilisant sur la
protection des mineurs en ligne
résolvez seulement par le prisme de
l'évitement des risques n'est donc pas
suffisant il est absolument nécessaire
de penser prévention éducation et
accompagnement tant des adultes que des
enfants et des adolescents
concernant le cyber-harcèlement l'option
retenue a été citée tout à l'heure par
Monsieur Gérard c'est une peine
complémentaire de suspension du compte
sur la plateforme pour les utilisateurs
condamnés pour une durée maximum de six
mois ceci pose plusieurs questions qui
interrogent la faisabilité effectivement
comment techniquement cela est-il
possible car toute utilisateur peut
recréer maintes comptes et changer l'IP
de son ordinateur grâce à un VPN je pose
donc la question comment techniquement
empêche-t-on je cite la création de
nouveaux comptes par la personne
concernée comme indiquée page 81 autre
point il est précisé je cite la peine de
suspension des contes ne sont concernent
que les services de plateforme en ligne
ayant été utilisés pour commettre
l'infraction or comme la remarquer
monsieur Gérard la clinique le terrain
les études sur le cyber-harcèlement
montrent qu'un cyber-harceleur n'opère
pas que sur un réseau social il peut
bouger d'un réseau social à un autre il
utilise en effet différents canaux cela
veut-il dire que si par exemple il a
opéré sur Instagram que son compte est
suspendu sur celui-ci et qu'il est
réitère le harcèlement sur un autre
réseau social la victime doit donc
procéder à un nouveau parcours du
combattant pour endiguer le ça le
harcèlement sur une autre plateforme
que prévoit alors le projet de loi dans
ce cas pour faciliter le parcours
juridique de la victime
grand absent de ce projet de loi les
témoins en ligne qui prennent une place
un peu différente des témoins dans la
vraie vie dans une situation de
harcèlement puisqu'ils sont présents en
masse comment la loi définit les témoins
en ligne du cyber-harcèlement reste ton
témoin lorsque nous faisons que liker
une publication ou que repartager une
publication ces actes qui n'impliquent
pas de commentaires textualisés mais sur
ajoutes au harcèlement sont-ils des
actes de harceleur ou reste-t-il des
actes de témoin si tel si tel est le cas
de cette question du témoin comment le
la loi définit les témoins en ligne et
que prévoit la loi pour ses témoins
il est aussi pointé que la peine
complémentaire de suspension de compte
dissuade les utilisateurs dont les
comptes ont déjà été suspendus à
récidiver également d'autres
utilisateurs qui pourraient être tentés
de se livrer à des comportements
similaires parce que 81 cet effet de
dissuasion est toute relative au profil
psychologique de la personne et ne peut
absolument pas être généralisée il est
ajouté que l'obligation pour les
plateformes d'empêcher la création de
nouveaux comptes par ses utilisateurs et
ses divistes prévient d'autant plus de
tels comportements et protège les
utilisateurs de contenu néfastes et
préjudiciable deux points sont à relever
quant à cette précision dans le projet
de loi premièrement la prévention des
comportements cyber-harcèlement et la
protection des utilisateurs ne peut se
penser que par cette seule voie
législative il est complètement utopiste
de croire qu'une interdiction empêche la
transgression
deuxièmement s'il existe de tels
comportements c'est qu'ils sont
préexistants aux usages des réseaux
sociaux
ce n'est pas l'usage de la plateforme
qui rend haineux ou agressif l'usage est
simplement une mise en lumière de
comportements préexistants ceci m'amène
à une question fondamentalement absente
de ce projet de loi que prévoit la loi
pour le condamné en tant qu'individu
s'inscrivant dans un groupe social
aujourd'hui les cyber-harceleurs malgré
la labilité des profils du fait
d'Internet qui rend possible largement
le grimage ou l'anonymat sont soit des
anciens harcelés soit des personnes
ayant une vécu de souffrance et se
construisant en leader négatif pour
réparer une faille narcissique ou
réparer leur estime de soi pour être
plus grossière ce sont donc des
personnes ayant des difficultés et étant
en souffrance
en amont une social une sensibilisation
plus forte des enfants et des
adolescents à l'être ensemble aux
collectif à l’interbande dépendance dans
la vraie vie et dans la vie numérique
parce que le cyber-harcèlement est une
question de groupalité au numérique ceci
implique d'intégrer au programme
scolaire avec une progression de la
maternelle au secondaire des modules
d'éducation médias et au numérique
décryptant d'abord pour les plus petits
les images des livres les images de
l'environnement de l'enfant puis celles
des écrans avec une attention
particulière sur la mise en lumière des
émotions éprouvées face à celle-ci ceci
permettrait de sensibiliser les enfants
à l'impact émotionnel des images qu'elle
soit sur un écran ou pas et cette
sensibilisation est essentielle pour
éviter la banalisation que l'on retrouve
dans les faits de cyber-harcèlement
puis une intégration progressive dans ce
programme à la notion de citoyens en
ligne ceci signifie les éveillés à
l'esprit critique sur les images ou
l'effet qu'il côtoie sur Internet leur
apprendre à discerner la source d'une
information ce qui veut dire discerner
la source d'un harcèlement en ligne
pardon et à croiser ses sources les
décupalibiliser à l'acte de signalement
aujourd'hui les adolescents n'osent pas
signaler sur les réseaux sociaux de peur
d'être pris pour des balances
les sensibiliser au phénomène de groupe
par des exercices engageant la
groupalité bien entendu leur apporter
une information associée à la
responsabilisation de leurs actes il
s'agit de former les enfants et les
adolescents à la vie numérique comme on
les forme au raisonnement mathématiques
en discipline de maths au collège
ceci me permet de rebondir sur un point
du projet de loi qui m'a
particulièrement interloqué et je
conclurai sur ça page 82 les impacts sur
la jeunesse sont qualifiés par le terme
néant
je n'ai peut-être pas tous les codes de
ce canton un projet de loi par impact
sur la jeunesse mais à mon niveau en
tant que psychologue clinicienne et
docteur en psychopathologie cela m'a
paru être un non-sens à ce projet de loi
en effet il apparaît important que cet
article du projet de loi est un impact
sur la genèse en terme de prévention
d'information mais surtout
d'accompagnement et d'éducation la
sanction doit avoir valeur
d'apprentissage elle doit être le
tremplin d'un accompagnement éducatif et
où psychologique la sanction que porte
cet article 5 du projet loi doit avoir
un impact sur la jeunesse car elle doit
affirmer la centralité de la loi et des
règles que ce soit dans l'espace public
réel ou dans l'espace numérique et ceci
favorise le vivre ensemble et la société
elle doit permettre de faire à devenir
un sujet responsable à même d'assumer
les conséquences de ses actes tout en le
rendant actif dans la réparation de soi
et de l'autre ceci doit engage donc un
après la sanction qui est celui de
l'accompagnement des protagon istes du
cyber-harcèlement sans en oublier aucun
harceleur témoin et victime je vous
remercie
merci à tous les trois avant de passer
la parole à notre rapporteur Louis kervé
puis à l'ensemble des membres de la
commission qui souhaiteront s'exprimer
mettez-moi juste de réagir sur la
question éducative madame vous avez eu
raison de la souligner elle est
essentielle mais il froide distinguer ce
qui est d'ordre de la loi et ce qui est
de l'ordre de son application par décret
et après par élaboration des programmes
éducatifs je voudrais signaler que
aujourd'hui en tout cas le Sénat il y a
participé très largement ces sujets sont
déjà inscrits au cœur du code de
l'éducation 2011
j'ai des rapporteur de la transposition
du paquet Telecom et nous avons fait
inscrire dans le code d'éducation
l'obligation d'une formation et d'une
sensibilisation des élèves au risque aux
menaces de l'Internet loi école de la
confiance juillet 2019 nous avons
réamendé aussi ce texte la commission de
la culture d'éducation du Sénat pour
spécifier ce que doit être la formation
des formateurs dans ce domaine très
précis dont vous avez d'ailleurs décliné
toutes les implications et toutes les
modalités vous avez pratiquement annoncé
le programme qui doit se mettre en œuvre
notre rôle c'est donc de contrôler
maintenant l'application de la loi et
des nous à le faire car chaque année
nous réinterrogeons du disque de
l'éducation nationale sur le sujet voilà
je tenais à le dire parce que de longues
dates le Sénat légiféré sur ces
questions c'est important de le
souligner donc ensemble à l'application
déjà de ce qui existe comme l'a dit tout
à fait justement monsieur tout à l'heure
monsieur le rapporteur
merci Madame présente ce sera plutôt une
réflexion étant donné que les
interventions de de nos trois
interlocuteurs ont été extrêmement
extrêmement complète et extrêmement
fouillée je voudrais devant la
commission spéciale devant vous madame
messieurs
vous dire que on est bien conscient de
la période dans laquelle nous
travaillons
dans laquelle on vient cet après-midi
d'apprendre que la Commission mixparita
a trouvé un accord sur la question
de précisément de la majorité numérique
que nous attendons une décision de
justice que le DMA lDSA vont rentrer
dans l'ordre
juridique français
des le mois d'août et en début d'année
prochaine que que on attend un ensemble
de nouveaux textes européens dont la
négociation n'est pas terminée
que un certain nombre de textes de lois
qui ont été adoptés à l'initiative d'un
certain nombre de collègues ici présents
ne font que quand très en vigueur et
quand on parle d'une entrée en vigueur
en France et de production d'effets
juridiques on en mesure l'effet qu'au
bout de quelques mois voire quelques
années
si je vous dis ça c'est que
à vous entendre
il faudrait simplement
si je schématise un certain nombre
d'interventions il faudrait simplement
appliquer ce qui existe déjà
attendre et voir si ça marche moi je
pense pas je pense pas ça du tout et ça
veut pas dire que ce qui a été fait est
mauvais
mais il faut accélérer massifier et je
le dis à la fois comme comme rapporteur
avec la présidente Marseille parce que
si on
estimait qu'il fallait rien faire alors
à ce moment on supprime l'article
premier article 2
et on ne s'occupe que de l'entrée du DMA
et du DSA dans leur durée interne et on
exclut les questions qui nous réunissent
cet après-midi quand je dis qu'il faut
accélérer et massifier c'est que et là
je le dis en tant que père de famille on
a rien réglé en réalité et toutes les
auditions qu'on mène celle de cet
après-midi mais celle qu'on a mené
jusqu'à maintenant nous montre cela
alors accélérer massifié ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que la question de
l'autorité judiciaire
capable de régler le problème nous
démontre
qu'en fait il y a très peu d'affaires
pendant devant les tribunaux et que
quand elles doivent être jugées elles
sont extrêmement lentes à juger on
attend précisément une affaire qui est
pendante mais on doit constater que
devant les tribunaux actuellement il y a
très peu d'instances judiciaires qui ont
été qui ont été ça me fait penser à la
faire à l'histoire de l'excision
il y a des milliers de jeunes filles
françaises qui sont concernés par ce ou
deux qui sont vivants en France qui sont
concernés par ce problème là il y a pas
d'affaires devant les tribunaux pas
parce que dans les tribunaux qui a pas
de problème le problème est majeur mais
on a du mal à l'appréhender et par la
justice on a donc la question de confier
à une autorité administrative
indépendante quel Arcome la définition
d'un cas d'un cahier des charges précis
qui est technique des techniques par
lesquelles on va essayer
de contrôler l'âge de ceux qui vont
consulter des contenus P de
pornographiques est une tentative mais
qui permet de massifier et d'accélérer
les choses et sa raison pour laquelle
moi j'aurais plutôt
tendance à essayer de regarder comment
on peut aller vers une rédaction qui
sont encore plus opérationnelles que
celles que propose du gouvernement mais
mais en aucun cas à tourner le dos à
cette nouvelle tentative qu'on va faire
de trouver une solution un problème qui
est considérable et je ne méconnais
absolument pas les difficultés
techniques qui sont posées
de ce texte là précis parce qu'on aurait
pu faire que on aurait pu même ne pas
faire de textes de loi parce que
dérèglement européen ne suppose pas en
général qu'on adapte le droit interne il
se trouve que il y a un effet quand même
sur leur durée du Quintin qui fait qu'on
doit quand même préciser un certain
nombre de choses et pour ces articles en
tout cas et les premiers articles du
texte le gouvernement a voulu
les inscrire je dois définitivement
comment le Parlement en particulier les
Sénat fort des travaux qui ont été ceux
de nos différents collègues ne
pourraient pas saisir cette occasion là
de d'essayer de faire avancer encore
plus ce
cette question qui est une question
vraiment
fondamentale pour pour la jeunesse de
notre pays
pas de question supplémentaires donc je
me tourne vers nos collègues la
commission madame Rossignol a déjà levé
la main allez-y
merci pour pour vos propos je dois dire
que j'avais pas entendu ni lui a entendu
encore ce que Arthur melon nous a dit
tout à l'heure au nom du coffrage et
j'écoute avec attention ce que dit le
coffrade et ce sud de nombreuses années
en fait
moi je pense comme vous voilà je pense
comme vous j'ai regardé ces trois
premiers articles en me demandant par
quel bout on peut bien attraper ça dans
l'espace qui nous est assigné c'est à
dire qu'il n'est consiste juste à
demander
un dispositif
dont je crains absolument comme vous que
en fait
il change pas grand chose en réalité il
change pas grand chose dans la réalité
la difficulté qu'on a c'est quelle autre
dispositif c'est ça notre problème alors
j'entends ce que oui c'est que c'est
peut-être encore pire avec celui-là
enfin du moins ça va servir d'alibi
aussi de quelle dispositif je pense
qu'un dispositif idéal consiste l'idéal
déjà j'ai mon point de vue sur la
pornographie que je pense être toxique
au delà des mineurs on commence comme ça
c'est pas le sujet qu'on nous donne à
traiter aujourd'hui mais un petit peu
difficile idéal c'est à chaque fois dès
qu'un site n'est pas conforme à la ouate
2020 et permet l'accès des mineurs on le
ferme voilà c'est ça le dispositif c'est
ça quand même chers collègues c'est
qu'on devrait pas
s'enfiler dans ce que le projet de loi
nous propose c'est à dire toute une
série de
référentiels de procédures de
notification voilà on devrait fermer le
site qui ne respecte pas loin et vous
avez raison de dire quand on a vu ça
dans aucun autre dispositif ou des gens
puissent dire ah mais moi j'applique pas
la loi parce qu'on ne donne pas l'état
ne me donne pas les moyens d'appliquer
la loi ça n'existe nulle part ailleurs
c'est comme le gars qui dit je paye pas
mes impôts parce que mon patron parce
que j'ai passé d'argent pour les payer
ça n'existe pas donc on est
effectivement quelque chose de très
particulier on bute sur un sujet qui est
pour moi la clé c'est le postulat comme
quoi il faut respecter l'anonymat et la
vie privée des consommateurs de porno
pour ceux qui ont le cœur accroché je
vous conseille de lire un article dans
le monde de cet après-midi sur une
affaire criminelle dans le Vaucluse avec
50 mise en examen pour viol et des
milliers d'images de viol d'une femme je
vous passe je suis pas là pour raconter
les journaux et des milliers d'images
pour être pédopornographique trouver
dans les ordinateurs des mises en examen
parce qu'on sait maintenant qu'il y a
entre le viol la pédoporn la
pédocriminalité
et la pornographie Des continuum voilà
il y a pas ceux qui regardent des images
de pédopornographie et puis ceux qui
remarquent des images de grandes
personnes et puis ceux qui regardent des
images et puis ceux qui passent jamais à
l'acte tout ça n'existe plus voilà
aujourd'hui on le sait c'est un
continuum c'est pas systématique fort
heureusement mais il faut la prendre
comme ça et donc le sujet sur lequel on
bute c'est et j'arrive pas à trouver
quel est le fondement juridique de ça
qu'est-ce qui justifie que les
consommateurs de porno et droit à
l'anonymat qu'aucun autre
usagé d'Internet ne revendiquent pour
aucune autre de ses activités pourquoi
ce qui marche pour les sites de jeux en
ligne ne peut pas fonctionner pour les
sites de porno par exemple j'ai toujours
pas compris et j'espère quand même que
notre commission va poser cette question
là enfin moi je l'ai posé on l'a posé
qu'est-ce qui où on bute est tant qu'à
faire à aller au Conseil constitutionnel
avec une QPC autant qu'on y aille pour
pour du lourd pardonnez-moi autant qu'on
y aille pour un gros truc parce que on
ira au Conseil constitutionnel ce texte
il sera
occupé c'est donc voilà je voulais vous
remercier et dire et dire à mes
collègues que on a une énorme
frustration parce qu'on a l'impression
que
on vit de la mer avec une petite
cuillère pour être prendre une
expression
merci Madame Rossignol madame Mercier
madame la présente nécessaire rapporteur
mais je connais donc j'ai écouté avec
une attention soutenue les différentes
interventions et évidemment bien sûr je
partage ce que vous avez dit je partage
aussi les propos de ma collègue Laurence
Rossignol on a vraiment l'impression de
radoter on a une loi qui impose le
contrôle de l'âge on sait contrôler
l'âge dans l'univers numérique on sait
le faire et ça ne fonctionne pas on bute
là dessus effectivement on bute or
l'anonymat qui est demandé par les
usagers pour les sites pornographiques
gratuits
mais quid du visionnage de films
pornographiques payant là il est plus
question d'anonymat donc pourquoi nous
butons sur ce problème du contrôle de
l'âge uniquement sur les sites
pornographiques gratuits il y a pas de
problème d'anonymat pour les jeux en
ligne pas du tout c'est uniquement là
dessus donc il y a forcément des raisons
qui nous échappent ou alors qu'on
commence à comprendre enfin qu'on
commence qu'on a compris qu'ils vont
bien trop loin et on ne s'embarque pas
la dent donc voilà pourquoi on a un
texte de loi qui se s'ajoute à quelque
chose qui existe déjà on l'a la loi
c'est obligatoire c'est obligatoire pour
les sites de s'assurer que des contenus
réservés aux adultes ne vont pas tomber
dans les yeux des enfants
voilà la question elle est toute simple
et on n'arrive pas à y répondre il
manque une volonté il manque je ne sais
pas quoi on se cache derrière l'Europe
on se cache derrière un tas de fausses
raisons mais on y arrive pas et ce
texte-là ne va pas nous permettre d'y
arriver davantage puisqu'on aura
effectivement une QPC je voudrais
terminer sur ce texte en me posant moi
la question sur l'article 15 qui
l'article 15 m'a quand même beaucoup
ennuyé cette histoire d'ordonnance
vous avez lu cet article 15 c'est c'est
vraiment un quelque chose d'incroyable
c'est-à-dire que ce qu'on n'arrive pas à
faire avec une loi on se dit que
peut-être par les ordonnances on va y
arriver pour jouer de l'argent puisque
il sujet il s'agit d'objets numériques
monétisable il y a monétisable dedans
donc là
oui mais pour
en ligne oui absolument on va ouvrir les
jeux d'argent en ligne c'est la partie
on est carrément au sujet de la table
ronde mais je te rassure Marie dehors de
questions qu'on laisse cet article dans
l'état et dans la démarche qu'on est en
train de faire c'est justement de
trouver une définition des jaunes parce
que c'est une région
pour pouvoir en sorte que bah on puisse
le proposer une rédaction effective mais
on laissera pas l'ordonnance ça c'est
sûr merci alors
du numérique
que le début merci beaucoup voilà Barry
c'est terminé l'intervention
alors j'ai eu le rapporteur le week-end
V qui soit d'intervenir à ce stade c'est
pour aussi faire en sorte que finalement
actif Bion vous répondra oui merci pour
une précision à l'égard de Marie Mercier
quand il y a un contenu qui est payant
il y a un contrat et il y a un paiement
voilà donc c'est comme un abonnement
ah bah non quand il y a un contrat à un
abonnement quelconque dans la vie il y a
il y a plus d'anonymes c'est le contrat
c'est le contrat l'existence du contrat
et souvent l'exigence du paiement qui
crée qui crée
l'identification de la personne par pour
les besoins de la cause et donc la
question de l'enjeu de ce texte c'est
précisément d'apporter une
réglementation une régulation quand il
n'y a pas de contrat et pour des
contenus qui ne sont pas soumis à une
identification préalable
parce que c'est
c'est exact en fait il y a des contenus
sur Internet de manière générale mais
des conduisant internet qui donne lieu à
une autre notification parce qu'il y a
un pays un contrat et un paiement il y a
tout le reste où le ou la navigation est
libre donc la question de la régulation
pour les contenus pornographiques à
l'égard des enfants
elle se pose là sur les contenus en
consultation libre
bien ces explications ayant été données
je passe la parole à négligion qu'il a
demandé et vous êtes plusieurs aussi de
l'avoir sollicité je vais vous la passer
juste après merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs messieurs
madame merci pour vos propos j'ai pas
vraiment véritablement de questions je
vais je vais juste réagir par rapport
aux propos que vous avez pu tenir et qui
ont fait écho aussi dans la salle tout à
l'heure moi je crois véritablement après
avoir travaillé avec mes collègues 6
mois sur l'industrie de la pornographie
avec porno l'enfer du décor que il y a
un avant et un après rapport c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui on a quand même un
texte qui affiche une volonté politique
alors le sujet est difficile mais
lorsqu'on a démarré nos travaux en
janvier 2022
la situation il regarde sur l'industrie
de la pornographie et le visionnage de
l'industrie pornographique qui était
quand même c'était une vision assez é
adoré assez gentille de la pornographie
on a permis de mettre en avant que ces
images elles étaient consultées par
énormément de mineurs qu'elle y avait
comme le disait la rapporteur Laurence
Rossignol une porosité entre
pornographie proxénétisme prostitution
et là où ces travaux faisaient un peu
sourire ils ont finalement amené des
réactions nous avons été à la rencontre
des ministres alors oui peut-être que ce
texte de loi ne va pas assez loin mais
il a l'avantage de proposer des choses
et je crois que
au sujet de l'arcome au sujet des
sanctions on doit essayer de tout mettre
en oeuvre en réalité pour rendre la vie
impossible à ces entreprises qui ne
respectent pas la loi lorsqu'elle existe
et ça a été rappelée par Marie merci à
l'instant c'est-à-dire que il y a des
lois elles doivent être respectées
madame la Présidente l'a dit il y a des
obligations d'éducation est-ce qu'elles
doivent être complétées est-ce que
l'éducation à la sexualité qui est
prévue actuellement dans la loi elle
doit être améliorée oui bien entendu il
s'agit pas de parler anatomie en classe
de 4e oui il faut une véritable
éducation au corps puisque des enfants
sont exposés à 8 ans à 9 ans à des
images pornographiques donc peut-être
que ce texte ne va pas assez loin mais
il faut alors là que vous nous aidiez à
l'améliorer pour qu'on puisse trouver
les outils pour rendre la vie impossible
à ces entreprises qui mettent sur des
plateformes et qui ne se conforment pas
à la loi qui sont d'ailleurs souvent
hébergées dans des paradis fiscaux et
qui n'est génèrent beaucoup d'argent il
faut qu'on leur rende la vie impossible
en réussissant à bloquer ces images qui
contreviennent à la loi et qui sont
accessibles aux mineurs ont également en
leur imposant des sanctions lourdes et
fortes et
qu'elle soit qu'elle soit payée aussi et
puis
au niveau des moyens il est question
dans tous vos propos de moyens si on
veut que la loi soit respectée il qu'on
donne des moyens je vous rejoins
également sur monsieur sur il y a une
loi et bien charge aux entreprises de se
mettre en conformité avec la loi lorsque
vous avez un vendeur d'un quelconque
produit il doit vendre des produits qui
sont qui respectent la loi c'est pas
c'est pas un organisme extérieur de de
l'aider à se conformer il se conforme
donc pour l'industrie de pornographique
c'est la même chose et donc inversement
de la charge du travail a mener non
c'est peut-être pas à l'état de trouver
tous les moyens c'est aux entreprises de
faire en sorte que ces images elles
soient à la fois finalement non
accessible aux mineurs mais que toutes
les images qui contreviennent à la loi
c'est-à-dire les viols le racisme la
pédocrinalité et bien que ces images
elles soient également finalement
bloquées mais elle ne doivent apparaître
pas du tout en fait c'est ça le sens de
vos interventions donc merci pour vos
propos qui étaient à la fois éclairants
et si vous avez des pistes
d'amélioration pour à la fois la
protection des mineurs mais au-delà la
protection de toute la société parce que
ces images pornographiques elles ne sont
pas et je rejoins ma collègue Laurence
Rossignol sur ce sujet elles ne sont pas
nuisibles et impactantes que pour les
mineurs je remercie merci Madame billon
alors ensuite madame bourra toi de
bourra
merci madame la Présidente alors moi je
voudrais revenir sur le sujet de
l'anonymat et du pseudonymat qui n'est
pas vraiment abordé dans le texte mais
je parle de l'anonymat et du pseudonymat
de manière générale parce que le vrai
fléau de dans le monde
numérique c'est et ce qui rend les
réseaux sociaux aussi puissants et aussi
incontrôlables c'est l'anonymat et le
pseudonymat donc j'aurais bien voulu
savoir moi quel était votre position sur
la levée éventuelle de l'anonymat du
pseudonymat surtout par le fait que le
pseudonymat permet la multiplicité de
compte à l'infini
madame borkout
madame la Présidente je voulais vous
remercier à mon tour Mesdames et
Messieurs les intervenants pour les
témoignages assez sincères et fidèles à
la réalité que vous venez de nous livrer
je partage pleinement les interventions
de mes collègues quel que soit les bords
politiques parce que c'est un sujet qui
fait consensus et la protection mineur
et vraiment une priorité pour nous en
tant que parlementaire je voulais juste
vous interroger sur deux sujets j'étais
là rapporteur de la proposition de loi
visant à une majorité numérique et et
sur la haine en ligne il y avait une
question dans cette proposition de loi
sur une meilleure visibilité des deux
numéros qui concernent notamment le
harcèlement qui sont le 30 18 et le
30/20 il y avait une volonté de
l'Assemblée nationale de fusionner ces
deux numéros en tout cas donc
soulevé probablement un manque de
visibilité donc je voulais avoir votre
avis sur sur cette question ensuite sur
une autre qui est celle de la prévention
des parents on a souhaité dans cette
proposition
de responsabiliser aussi les boutiques
d'applications logicielles et les
systèmes d'exploitation je vais pas les
citer mon les connais tous je pense que
chacun doit apporter sa pierre dans
cette responsabilité ça suffit pas que
d'interdire les plateformes numériques
de pornographie de d'interdire
uniquement les réseaux sociaux mais
aussi d'impliquer tous ceux qui
concourent en tout cas à l'accès à ces
contenus une appropriés donc j'envisage
et on sera le premier pays dans le monde
à le faire justement de les
responsabiliser de les obliger à aussi
être vigilant parce que les données on
sait très bien qu'ils les ont donc c'est
la première voie d'accès et l'unique
accès d'ailleurs aux applications
logicielles de passer par ces boutiques
donc si eux font le premier filtre je
pense que ça permettra de limiter
justement l'accès des mineurs à des
contenus inappropriés
vous avez raison de le soulier c'est
amendement qu'on y a travaillé avec
Annick Billon et vous-même pour le
dernier texte de loi mais c'est dans
cette loi SRN je crois qu'il trouvera
toute sa place et il est très important
de pouvoir améliorer le texte à cet
effet donc on aura certainement pas mal
de manière encore améliorer cette
proposition alors Monsieur Ray Charles
qui a été court à porteur je tiens à le
dire du projet de règlement visant à
prévenir et lutter contre les abus
sexuels sur les enfants liés aux
plateformes
ce qui est dire si le sujet est pris
vraiment au sérieux au niveau européen
c'est qu'on s'interroge aussi sur une
législation Haddock le phénomène est
vraiment extrêmement important voilà
Monsieur Aïcha
[Musique]
sur ce texte j'ai encore beaucoup de
choses à apprendre il y a plein de
choses que je ne sais pas première
question que je voudrais poser à titre
pour mon information plusieurs millions
de consultations de sites
pornographiques gratuits est-ce qu'on a
un chiffre sur les consultations de
sites pornographiques payants est-ce que
ça doit se trouver ça quelque part à
titre à titre d'information et de
comparaison
vraiment pour essayer de comprendre
[Musique]
alors c'est ce que je pensais voilà
c'est ce que je pensais moi c'est ce que
mais mais tout à fait parce que moi
j'avais cru comprendre qu'effectivement
on commence par visionner un site
gratuit pour ensuite déboucher sur un
site payant ultérieurement
voilà c'était le c'était une des raisons
de ma question donc est-ce qu'on est-ce
qu'on a ça mais vraiment à titre
d'information perso deuxièmement si on
ne sait pas maintenant on va peut-être
se renseigner deuxièmement pour essayer
de comprendre toujours
obligation faite par le projet de loi à
l'arcom de fournir des lignes
directrices pour vérifier contrôler la
majorité
une fois qu'on a fait ça une fois que
l'arcom a fourni des lignes directrices
il se passe quoi
non mais clairement il se passe quoi
est-ce que j'ai bien compris que c'est
un simple coup de d'épée dans l'autre on
est bien d'accord avec ça bon
est-ce qu'il y a-t-il et la
techniquement je sais pas techniquement
il y a-t-il une autre façon de procéder
que l'on pourrait t'inscrire dans le
projet de loi
pour faire en sorte qu'effectivement il
y ait un une une un contrôle
obligatoire
et et et efficient voilà efficace de la
majorité parce que moi je vois pas à
quoi ça sert on se gargarise à l'heure
actuelle la communication c'est vous
allez voir demain on va empêcher
les jeunes de pouvoir consulter tous ces
sites pornographiques pornographiques
gratuits mais
on empêche rien du tout en détail ce que
j'ai bien compris ça on empêche rien du
tout
alors sur les questions posées
à nos invités donc je les laisse
répondre après s'il rapporte le redire
quelque chose
qui souhaite prendre la parole monsieur
J'ai rare peut-être pour commencer
sur certains certaines aspects d'abord
juste
ça a été évoqué la question de l'article
15 et des ordonnances notamment pour
définir le cadre des genoux
effectivement on est dans l'idée c'est
de créer quelque chose qui soit qui soit
à l'interstice entre jeux d'argent et je
dois dire etc on est d'accord sur le
fait qu'on est sur un objet un peu
spécifique pour autant et moi il me
semble qu'il y a quand même des là aussi
des des enjeux en termes de protection
des enfants qui ne sont pas minimiser et
je pense que
on a nous été étonné sur le fait que
voilà qu'on laisse les le cadre fixé par
par des dispositifs d'ordonnance et qui
a véritablement des des enjeux
aujourd'hui et demain à venir autour de
vous j'arrête juste parce que on ne le
laisse pas d'abord le texte n'a pas été
encore débattu lorsqu'il sera débat
qu'on le laisse donc d'accord sachez que
nous c'est quelque chose
même pas commencé et comme l'a dit notre
rapporteur Patrick chaise vous pensez
bien que ça nous a pas échappé ça a été
le premier pratiquement le sujet qu'on a
observé donc ne vous inquiétez pas le
Sénat n'aime pas beaucoup les
ordonnances d'abord OK
alors il y a quelques questions très
précises qui ont été qui ont été posées
d'abord on a été osé sur la question de
la visibilité des deux numéros
la fusion du 30 18 et du transit pour
faire simple
sur ces questions en général on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui l'important c'est au
contraire c'est d'aller vers quelque
chose qui soit le plus le plus percutant
et le plus utile pour pour le grand
public et que même si le le service qui
entre guillemet proposé derrière ces
deux numéros n'est pas sensiblement le
même aujourd'hui le nous ce qui remonte
sur le terrain c'est qu'on sait qu'on se
perd finalement sur au fond sur tous ces
numéros et qu'on qu'on a à nouveau on
renvoie la responsabilité de l'enfant ou
du parents qui souhaitent appeler à
choisir le le bon numéro qu'il faudrait
être sans doute aller vers quelque chose
qui aurait plus du guichet unique et
d'avoir un numéro assez simple on est
face à situation de de difficultés
autour du harcèlement mais on peut on
peut avoir ça sur d'autres aspects et il
faut que le numéro soit immédiatement
accessible et qu'on n'est pas à se poser
la question en disant à ce que je dois
appeler tel ou tel numéro etc donc on
est plutôt on a plutôt nous sur le
terrain demande de simplifier tout ça et
d'avoir un seul numéro vous avez
également évoqué la question de
de la prévention notamment auprès des
parents de l'accompagnement enfin je l'a
permis internet
il y a véritablement à nouveau un enjeu
d'accompagner et de redonner une
place aux parents qui ont la joie à
condition de pouvoir leur permettre
d'exercer leur rôle de parents et il y a
véritablement aujourd'hui à renforcer à
redonner
la possibilité aux parents de de jouer
ce rôle alors est-ce que ça doit passer
par des dispositifs
de de type accompagnement
sensibilisation ou aller plus loin il y
a aujourd'hui des réflexions qui sont
menées par exemple avec
pix qui vient mettre en place un pics
par an avec quels sont aujourd'hui
qu'elles sont finalement les compétences
de base qu'on doit avoir en tant que
parents pour pouvoir accompagner ses
enfants quels sont les les éléments dont
il faut disposer donc ça a une réflexion
qui est en cours avec l'objectif
d'atteindre la mise l'ouverture du
dispositif fin 2024 début 2025 donc on
est sur un calendrier assez long en tout
cas ça fait partie des des réflexions
moi je n'ai pas d'informations sur les
sites payants sur sur la réalité de leur
place dans le marché par rapport
à l'ensemble de du de l'accès à la
pornographie donc je ne répondrai pas
et puis et puis et puis
est-ce qu'il y a
donc voilà moi c'était les principaux
éléments et je pourrais compléter ouais
voilà Arthur monsieur melon vous vouliez
apporter quelques compléments
d'information oui assez rapidement pour
revenir d'abord sur les observations du
rapporteur monsieur rapporteur Hervé sur
effectivement les délais de justice qui
aujourd'hui sont extrêmement longs et on
est les premiers à le à le déplorer
simplement rappeler que si son nom c'est
aussi parce qu'il y a eu de nombreuses
manœuvres dilatoires de la part des
plateformes d'abord il y a eu
malheureusement un vice de procédure
dans la part de l'arcom par rapport à
des délais de notification qui n'avaient
pas été respectées ce qui a nécessité de
relancer une nouvelle procédure et ça
retarder de plusieurs mois le fait de
citer les fournisseurs d'accès devant le
tribunal judiciaire il y a eu également
lors de la première audience
l'injonction de rencontrer un médiateur
entre la com les fournisseurs d'accès
Internet et les plateformes
pornographiques ce qui est quand même
assez étonnant puisque on demande un
régulateur chargé de faire respecter la
loi de négocier avec les structures qui
se mettent en qui ne respectent pas la
loi donc on a été très surpris de de
cette injonction de médiation qui n'a
pas donné lieu à un accord et puis il y
a eu également donc cette question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité
qui a été rendu je crois l'arrêter rendu
peut-être aux alentours du mois de mars
ou avril durant le printemps donc c'est
aussi pour ces raisons que que la
procédure judiciaire est extrêmement
longue donc je suis encore une fois le
premier à déplorer le fait que
effectivement quand on veut des mesures
d'urgence se faire passer
les décisions par le juge ça ça prend du
temps aujourd'hui en revanche je pose la
question si on demande aujourd'hui à la
recom de faire ce travail il y a-t-il
des moyens supplémentaires qui sont
reloués pour que l'arcane puisse avoir
un service dédié et puisse être aussi
diligent ou plus diligent que la justice
aujourd'hui rien ne garantit que l'arcom
aura les capacités humaines de faire le
travail plus rapidement que ne peut ne
peut le faire aujourd'hui le
magistrageux je pose la question
on a très largement posé la question des
moyens ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui ou
même il y a quelques jours depuis que il
y a une montée en puissance des services
sur Internet et que l'art comme se voit
graduellement proposer et donner plus de
missions nous ne cessons de proposer
aussi des amendements loi de finances
pour doter pas seulement la recomie à
Lancy l'acnil l'accepte ce sont des
autorités de régulation et maintenant le
pérenne demain aussi ont besoin de
beaucoup plus de moyens qu'aujourd'hui
c'est une évidence donc on plaidera
vraiment ce sujet à la fois lors du
débat et on le voit de finances vous
pouvez compter sur nous à ce sujet à
titre d'illustration le coffret de
l'Open et Luna ont saisi de nouveau
l'arcom fin août à l'encontre cette
fois-ci de Twitter qui sur sa plateforme
laisse des contenus pornographiques
pédopornographiques et zoophile à ce
jour on n'a pas de nouvelles de ce
qu'elle a comme a fait de notre saisine
donc là on voit que c'est pas forcément
plus rapide quand il s'agit de donner à
l'arc comme la possibilité d'agir sur
ces dossiers
je reviendrai aussi donc sur la question
de l'exigence de respect des données
personnelles de respect de la vie privée
et c'est assez curieux de voir comment
les plateformes pornographiques
bénéficient d'une sorte de régime
d'exception sur cette question du
respect de la vie privée les plateformes
pornographiques seraient beaucoup plus
scrupuleuses que tous les autres
services numériques sur le respect de
l'anonymat puisque quand il s'agit de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'a mangé un tel à
midi ça pose pas de problème à Facebook
quand il s'agit de connaître la religion
l'orientation sexuelle ou l'orientation
politique de quiconque sur les réseaux
sociaux ça ne pose visiblement
absolument aucun problème quand il
s'agit effectivement de donner ces sa
carte bleue ou son nom par rapport pour
faire des paris sportifs alors j'entends
qu'il y a la question du contrat mais on
ne se pose pas la question du respect
des données personnelles du respect de
la vie privée mais là c'est extrêmement
important quand ils agissent de
pornographie de surtout garantir que les
internautes soient en parfaite
tranquillité par rapport à l'anonymat et
je pose la question pourquoi cette
scrupule pourquoi ce régime d'exception
quand il s'agit de pornographie alors je
rappelle d'ailleurs que la Cour de
cassation dans son arrêt à estimer que
la loi actuelle qui présente des mots
qui présentent des contraintes
incontestables vis-à-vis de ces
plateformes la Cour de cassation
estimait que la loi avait des moyens
proportionnés par rapport à l'exigence
de protection des mineurs donc on
devrait au contraire être moins
regardant j'ai envie de dire sur la
protection des données de l'anonymat
quand il s'agit justement de prendre des
mesures pour protéger les mineurs que
pour tous les autres services sur
lesquels les millions de Français que
nous sommes mettent tous les jours leurs
informations personnelles et leur donner
pour n'importe quel autre service
[Musique]
et je crois que j'ai dit essentiellement
ce que j'avais à répondre
alors je redonne la parole à notre
rapporteur
les articles premiers deux bon bien sûr
que
c'est pas une obligation en l'air chers
collègues c'est bien une obligation
c'est la définition d'un cahier d'un
cahier des charges techniques
qui sera l'objet d'une délibération de
l'art comme après avis de la CNIL c'est
ensuite des opérations de vérification
que le contrôle là j'ai bien
opérationnel et ensuite il y a un régime
de sanctions c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas un régime de qui affirme simplement
une obligation
cette obligation elle est sortie d'un
certain nombre de sanctions et sur la
question de confier ça à l'arcom c'est
un choix c'est un choix politique qui
sera fait ou pas à l'échelle de ce texte
là c'est ce que le gouvernement amène
sur la table
avec ce texte là ce texte de loi là et
avec des moyens mais dans la présence le
vient dans le rappeler des moyens qui
sont les moyens de l'arcom à l'instant t
il faudra évidemment j'imagine renforcer
je le dis étant moi-même très attaché
aux libertés publiques et notamment au
étant conscient que dans notre pays
c'est plutôt le jujudiciaire qui le
défenseur de liberté publique
est-ce que avec le fait de confier ça
une autorité administrative indépendante
plus technique
plus proche des réalités du monde
numérique est-ce que on aura une réponse
plus massive et plus opérationnelle
c'est un choix que législateur sera
amené à faire ou pas mais ne pas le
faire ça veut dire qu'on en reste au
droit actuel droit positif et à la
situation que nous connaissons avec très
peu d'affaires portées devant les
tribunaux et des délais de jugement qui
sont considérables les manœuvres
dilatoires c'est un jugement de valeur
moi j'ai pas suivi l'affaire en soi vous
vous estimez que c'est parce que vous
êtes parti en plus à cet instant
évidemment le principe d'une juridiction
judiciaire c'est le principe du
contradictoire et moi aussi j'étais très
surpris qu'on confie qu'on lance une
opération de médiation c'est le juge qui
leur donnait
enfin je veux dire ok maintenant donc
on peut on peut s'en étonner on peut
mais on peut même être contre on peut
s'en indigner sauf que c'est bien dans
le respect de du fonctionnement
ordinaire des juridictions judiciaires
françaises que ça s'est produit ainsi et
voilà donc c'est pour faire ces deux
précisions dans la prison en m'excusant
de devoir malheureusement vous quittez
à une question de Monsieur concernant la
proportion entre les sites gratuits et
citoyens alors j'ai pas la réponse mais
on a encore une fois il y a l'enquête de
Mediamétrie commandée par l'arcom qui
donne un indice c'est que selon cette
enquête 60% des contenus pornographiques
consommés par les mineurs proviendrait
de cinq plateformes les cinq plateformes
étant des plateformes gratuites donc je
ne sais pas parmi les 40% restants
lesquels comment se répartit comment se
répartissent les contenus entre les
plateformes payantes et gratuite mais je
pense quand même une écrasante majorité
proviennent de plateformes gratuites et
je pense que
aujourd'hui si on a par exemple 7
juillet une décision du tribunal qui
demande au fournisseur d'accès de
suspendre les plateformes
pornographiques gageons qu'elle
trouveront tout de suite une solution
technique pour se mettre en conformité
avec la loi et pouvoir republier leur
contenu je pense que que cette question
des des
difficulté technique c'est plus un
prétexte pour continuer aujourd'hui à
pouvoir publier des contenus gratuits
qu'une vraie question
juridique qui se pose ou technique qui
se pose pour les plateformes donc moi je
serai curieux de de voir une fois qu'il
y aura une décision pour sanctionner
l'une de ces plateformes la créativité
l'inventivité que vont avoir les autres
plateformes pour trouver par miracle des
solutions qui permettront de contrôler
l'âge des internautes
c'est vrai qu'on peut leur faire
confiance pour avoir recours à toutes
les astuces possibles vous aviez je
voulais intervenir en amour à vous avez
une dernière parce que je n'ai pas eu de
réponse
concernant ma question sur le
pseudonymat alors j'ai bien compris
souvent avec l'anonymat on nous oppose
l'argument de la liberté d'expression
bien que je ne vois pas en quoi le fait
de ne pas être anonyme de nous permettre
pas enfin en quoi le fait d'être anonyme
ou pas non en quoi le fait de ne pas
être anonyme en pêche voilà de
s'exprimer librement pourquoi il
faudrait à tout prix être anonyme soit
mettons de côté la partie d'anonymat
j'aimerais bien avoir votre votre avis
concernant les pseudonymat parce que à
partir du principe ou une même personne
le même détenteur d'un compte peut
ouvrir des centaines de comptes via des
pseudonymes différents déjà on peut
s'interroger sur l'intérêt ou là ce qui
se cache derrière donc votre position
par rapport à le fait de maintenir de ne
pas du tout discuter des pseudonymats
dans le monde du de l'Internet
oui j'avais noté qu'on avait pas répondu
à votre question
alors sur la question de laonymat et du
pseudonymat en effet c'est un enjeu qui
est très important puisque ça favorise
en tout cas la clinique le montre bien
la levée des inhibitions et ça accroît
les inconduites sur les réseaux sociaux
à ceci s'ajoute que ça participe à une
pratique qui s'appelle le trolling et
les raids qui sont des pratiques de
d'agressivité diffamation en masse sur
sur les réseaux sociaux et donc
quand même dire que s'il y a pseudonymat
ou anonymat il y a quand même un compte
qui est affilié à ceci et en tout cas
une adresse IP là rejoint en effet la
question de la protection des données
personnelles mais peut-être qu'il y a
quelque chose à jouer pour dans ces cas
d'agressivité en ligne et de n en ligne
lever
anonymat et le pseudonymat face à ces
situations de cyber-harcèlement
ce que je voulais dire peut-être pour
remettre les choses en perspective
consciente et vous nous rappeler les
enjeux autour de ces sujets et
de la gravité de ces sujets que nous
partageons c'est notre préoccupation
c'est là vous avez vu les travaux qui
ont été qui ont été réalisés c'est que
nous sommes dans un texte d'application
de règlement européen d'au moins trois
règlements européens plus un par
anticipation je pense au data actes qui
c'est un texte qui a fait l'objet de
négociation entre les États membres dans
le cas aussi du trilogue conseil
Parlement etc
et que sans doute c'est un texte en tout
cas je dis aussi pour ma part et puis
ma collègue Florence Patrice contact on
a beaucoup travaillé au sein de la
Commission européenne
il y aurait une solution extrême qui
serait de responsabiliser complètement
les plateformes mais leur conférer un
troisième statut entre hébergeur éditeur
et remettre très profondément en cause
aussi leur modèle économique
voilà qui est en fait aussi le vecteur
est rend possible toutes ces dérives
puisque ces rémunérateurs tout ça il
faut bien se le dire voilà donc ce sont
des propositions d'ailleurs dont on
débat qu'on a aussi évoqué
Florence donc là on est dans un
compromis
vers une amélioration une étape quoi
qu'on en dise qui n'écrase pas le
comment dirais-je le droit pénal et tous
les crimes que vous avez évoqués qui
restent tout à fait
condatables et pris en compte par la
justice une justice qui ne va pas assez
vite ça on est bien d'accord avec avec
tout cela mais le vrai sujet c'est la
difficulté qui avoir après avoir pris
sur ces plateformes qu'on a laissé
prospérer grandir devenir des monstres
finalement qui dévorent tout sur leur
passage et qui reconfigurent nos
sociétés l'économie de celle-ci les
rapports de force au sein aussi du
marché numérique donc il y a là une
tentative de reprise en main
de réouverture cette directive
e-commerce de 2004 pour se dire ça peut
plus être la jungle définitivement donc
il faut il faut ces étapes elles sont
absolument
nécessaires je dirais que si le texte
n'est sans doute pas
parfait ça c'est clair
il a le mérite de consulter un minima
une prise de conscience collective où
tout le monde va se mettre en ordre de
marché c'est déjà pas si mal je le dis
parce que avec des moyens dédiés parce
qu'il en faut
voilà donc nous nous sommes attentifs on
en est à l'étape des auditions je vous
le cache pas donc c'est très intéressant
de vous avoir écouté aujourd'hui ça
permet de nous sensibiliser encore plus
au sujet ça permet aussi de se redire
qu'il faut faire valoir aussi ce qui
existe déjà dans la loi j'ai parlé du
côté éducatif ça existe tout et dans la
loi déjà dans le code d'éducation mais
maintenant on a un gros travail de moyen
dédié
d'évaluation régulière de contrôle du
Parlement du gouvernement de l'action
des ministères sur ces sujets voyez il y
a tout un travail de fond qu'il faut
faire collectivement donc merci de nous
avoir éclairé sur la question on va y
être extrêmement bien sûr attentive voir
comment on peut améliorer des choses
dans les jours qui viennent mais je
voulais juste replacer c'est pas un
texte à doc qui sort comme ça de la
plume du du gouvernement c'est un texte
d'application d'un règlement européen
d'ailleurs qui va s'appliquer
uniformément sur l'ensemble des 27 États
membres on a auditionné tout à l'heure
le directeur de RuPaul qui explique bien
aussi que ces réseaux de la
pédopornographie ce sont des réseaux
transfrontières donc il faut souvent
appréhender même parfois bien au-delà de
l'Europe en coopération internationale
pour démanteler les gangs qui font aussi
bénéfices grâce aux plateformes et la
viralité de ces plateformes et tout ce
qu'elle propose qui donc il faut
appréhender aussi c'est la question de
façon transnationale d'où gratos qui au
moins un socle minimal de législation
harmonisée au niveau européen sur la
question voilà donc on est dans un
ensemble un peu complexe pour lequel il
faut utiliser en fait différents outils
moi je pense pour pouvoir aborder le le
sujet tout en portant une grande forme
d'exigence que vous avez raison de
mettre de mettre en avant voilà on
voulait vous le dire en tout cas je vais
conclure cette table ronde à moins que
quelqu'un ait encore quelque chose à
ajouter sur le sujet en tout cas on est
toujours attentif à vos remarques si
vous avez encore des remarques à nous
fournir n'hésitez pas à nous les
communiquer nous sommes bien sûr
preneurs et encore une fois je vous
souhaite une bonne fin de journée merci
d'être venu au Sénat